[Music]
lef koe man with Westbrook yeah the
rocket man yes
and special guest loaf at the tubu has
he grown the man brother I get a
nickname yeah he came out with his own
I came out with my own that's our rule
so Lofa Blanc to tupa what do you want
it to be take your time take your time
yeah he likes to put you in the spot I
want to give respect to your full name
can you say your full name for me please
mo seola maiya a loafer - too beautiful
love it and what's interesting is
there's a moment behind you so if we
take your camera right now that really
messed me up so in that picture right
behind you ooh I'm an Eagles fan
Westbrook I think you're on that team oh
Lofa had three interceptions against the
Eagles football
oh no timeout time I'm sorry we're going
right there duster
first of all you didn't even tell me
about the pitcher that's number one well
like it's literally there's right that's
this kind of selfish and number two
that's our team I know that this all
went down but he's our guest okay yes
make an exception but the reason that I
really learned about like your heritage
and everything was because you did that
and it was an honoring I believe of
AIESEC a hammer who was also of Samoan
descent yeah
my apologies Polynesian alright but it
was it was this moment that the entire
country was like how cool is this and I
remember being at home being like stop
intercepting AJ Feeley right now all
night well it was it was paying homage
to not just vibe but also my linebacker
coach in college Kenny no in June yeah
Kenny any time you know yeah three times
whoo bull champion Pro Bowler any time
he made a play it was him paying homage
to his dad the boxes wow yeah is there
anyone doing this right now like can we
make this a thing that keeps going are
you allowed to celebrate these days I
you know I don't know the guys are
celebrating their butts up they're doing
they're doing dance to be a team
celebration which is cool I do like that
Seattle is one of the
her team said celebrating I did see that
laugh that's all whole defense is
sounded not just the guys on the ball
just on the field I saw the entire
defense go to the endzone off the
sidelines that's a sickening Saint
started this a few years ago or if they
get a pick or a turnover
they all run down they all celebrate
that's you like that you know act like
you've been there before you know throw
the ball back okay you know next play
he's being modest because here's the
deal
we played Seattle several times and it
wasn't when he scored a touchdown it was
when I'm when you're helping me up off
the ground because you just smacked me
in the mouth
that's what's going on great guy Lopez
is a great guy you can tell those great
guys throughout the game they help you
up there kind things like that but they
also when they get a chance to knock the
piss out of you so was there a moment
that you remember I can't remember I
just remember getting up 51 not again
Brown no sir it's not again so in
between the whistles yeah it's you know
you are that that alter ego you that
that wild man just get out that beast if
you will and you know but once that
whistles blown it's you know we're all
brothers that's right that's the respect
factor can i hump him up really quick
absolutely okay just because I know that
so like he did play at Maine for a year
before he went to USC how did that
matchup go well fuh how did that matchup
go I let Brad salad then I'll tell the
truth okay I was in my prime I was kind
of you know where things were they were
making sense I was some a few years
older than you would be you're born in
83 84 32 okay so I was a few years old I
was born in 79 so I was at the end of my
college time when you were probably just
a freshman and so we were we were
rolling a little bit I was I had things
going on well you're the all-time
leading yard get her at NCAA's not was a
player of the year in college that yeah
I was I had things going on it was it
was a good year for me how was that game
the Huggins mean I think you guys end up
beating us right
personally it was like record-breaking
for you and I think you played two
quarters well it went well it went well
I could tell that story
over here oh so the whole week you know
it was gonna be one of my first starts
and I was trading in that time because
someone in front of me the guy Rob here
said had gone down with an ankle injury
and so I'm studying film and just
watching you know Wes do his thing and I
was like okay so I got in there and on
the first play I got in there I broke
through the line and I did make a tackle
and I'm and I'm talking noise right and
he looks up he goes alright the next
play was a 75-yard screen pass for a
touchdown in which the first time my
angle ever got beat you've been able to
grunt ooh the sidelines and chase a guy
down well that's the game is all about
angle especially when you a four eight
forty guy like Mary sorry but and then I
want to say between kick return par
return yards of scrimmage it was over
300 or in one half yeah because you hurt
your ankle yes right there court right
things were well I think so
we were down 41 to 20 and half home come
on
yeah we're just getting to our
homecoming we were yeah incredible and
we came all the way back we won for that
by a field goal 44 to 41 that's alright
that we kick a squib kick they pick it
up and they go to about the 50 he
hobbles onto the field taped out stop
runs down out jumps everybody catches it
makes two guys miss dives and our safety
just catches them at the one like this
we're this far away I mean I'm right
there like Mike Jones all right they're
all making the table and Kevin Dyson
just how did you how do you jump
everybody after you have a high ankle
sprain and so like you out it was it was
a good game but we ended up losing
that's one of the four rare stories
where both of you come out looking great
you got the W you had the all-time
performance it was incredible that's
pretty great no this is I'm gonna fast
forward to that game that you're talking
about in Philly the Monday night for the
Monday Night Football so that was the
one of the most depressing games I've
ever watched well as just imagine me so
I'm seeing low focus for you we're
watching the tape though we're seeing a
linebacker make all the place but KJ
right and then Wagner this is the this
is the brains and this is how it started
in Seattle this guy right here he was
able to make every
he knew all so part of it he just talked
about watching film part of breaking
down offices is knowing Conor have an
idea what's gonna happen before you get
serious
smart smart football players like Lofa
they know what's gonna happen Andy Reid
was predictable so up screen here it
comes and they're calling it out and now
I'm in the backfield like oh yeah it is
a screen yeah he is just hoping that
somebody blocks the middle - my thing
what I hear football players say is when
you have a Zach Thomas when you yes your
sale where the quarterback gets to the
line and he's handing it off to the left
and the linebacker like ten seconds
early goes they're coming into the a guy
already left and the quarterback goes
[ __ ] man I'm sorry give it to you Dan
but the beauty is when you watch the
game obviously I'm on the other side and
so you don't appreciate it during the
game actually you hate it but now when
you're playing you're like I mean after
the game you're like you're just
watching them lie back and move
understands the how to beat an offensive
lineman how understands how to tackle
yes all to do all the right things this
is their prime example that's and I
listen I know you're coached in Seattle
and I know you coach both for those guys
out there some of the best linebackers
in the league and I know they're
talented guys I have to believe you talk
both of those guys right as well as
Wagner something that has made them to
the potential that they've reached at
this point because they're special guys
but it started with you I remember
playing against you he started with you
for sure I
I would love to take so credit but I
really you know Kenny know and did a
phenomenal job and then I got to the you
know the honor of learning under Michael
Barrow who fan growing up so you know
the foundation was in place and you know
there were certain things you know that
I would you know try to further their
football IQ would KJ was more of a you
know take more chances and not take
chances but calculated risks like you
were saying breaking down intense he's
breaking down formation down in distance
time of the clock what the offense
corner is natural you know play calling
rhythm is you get that in you know sync
and not to punt on their last
celebration but it's just it's chess not
checkers out there and it's just so much
easier
when you know where your help is and
where you can take your shot there was a
moment just now that I need to settle in
because I think it's a developing story
lining the season you said Andy Reed
gets predictable huh you laughed and the
reason that I think about it is you did
laughs I watched it happen but the
reason it's interesting to me is this is
kind of what we've seen with Andy Reed
and now we're in that weird October
November month where Andy always kicks
the NFL's ass in September and then we
kind of go this is what they're doing
and we learn their tendencies again for
the record Sammy Watkins has hurt their
left tackles out and they just got
Tyreke Hill back but are you guys seeing
anything right now about the cheese for
your like it's a little predictable I
just think the Andy has gotten so far
out of balance run pass that yeah it's
predictable cuz you know there's gonna
be a pass play and that means the
defensive linemen are teeing off they're
saying we don't have to worry about the
run-in even if they do run nobody cares
we'll find a way to tackle the sean
mccoy eight carries for mccoy last week
in the game where you're up big early so
yeah they're predictable because they're
throwing the ball almost every play I
told you last week I'm early this week
that when you have a player like Patrick
mahomes and this is this is not to say
that you shouldn't get a player like
this but the truth is when you have a
player like him because he's special
happened in Aaron with Aaron Rodgers in
Green Bay they're so special
you're saying this put the ball in their
hands here allowed them to go win the
game Andy Reid has that problem because
pass from our homes is that good the
problem is is that you have to have a
well-rounded team I'm worried about
Patrick Thursday night alright Denver
like they get a little bit but what do
you think like when you played Andy weir
like and since you're such a big like
film study or were you like do you
remember now like what the tendencies
were and do you ever see it when you
watch the Chiefs now oh yeah even down
to specific plays but I don't see it
with you know he's doing some things
that I was not accustomed to I know you
know the play look better on the
offensive side but terms of formation
recognition there you know there's some
things that are always gonna be that's
who you are
as a coach if it's something you know
that he believes in what he's seen work
and he's just put his twist onto it
what's it an andy screen like when you
he he loves screens and so if you get
out of that first 15 which is scripted
you know in that West Coast office then
you know
if you haven't seen one then you're
gonna get maybe one or two you know I
have two defensive questions and then
we're gonna get to the cup and then
we're gonna get to your bag number one
I'm thinking about like you just talking
about clock recognition in the down and
distance when I watch an offense huddle
it's one guy
and everyone's intently listening and
then as they hear their responsibilities
they peel off the Y receivers run out
and you could tell he's not getting the
ball the way he's running out like you
could tell sometimes language with the
defensive huddle it's like I see one guy
go Raider and then they all it's as our
defensive guys paying attention to the
down in distance like what are you guys
doing in the huddle and before the snap
it's a wild and this happens about 60 to
70 times a game right that's how many
plays are and it's a wild you know just
a chaotic even sequence of okay the
balls lined up form the huddle right and
in the huddle I got my safety giving me
the down in distance I'm looking at time
o'clock well now we have those
headphones or that microphone in your
helmet so it made things a lot easier
until that goes out because it used to
be hand signals back in the day and so
what did make easier with the hand
signals was that the whole defense the
secondary could get on the same page
with it and that's how we communicate in
the deafening noise that is you know
Stadium but um that from there the might
will linebacker Leroy Hill who came in
as a rookie with me he would give me the
personnel so you know 12 you know one
bag two tight ends 21 two bags one tight
and so the way the public thinks it's
like they think whoever has the dot on
their helmets in charge of everything
but for you to tell me that like
different there was a different guy
responsible for everything you got a
delegate you know responsibility what if
one of them goes out on a play then next
we'll back ask the tease go into the
backfield and tell me who's coming on
who's going sir Lee isn't it and so I'm
thinking and hearing all this while I'm
looking at this I don't know getting the
play because then in the two minute
there's no communication and it's
communication and everything you know
life is you know just key so the more
you know the easier it is out there and
that sounded something we stressed
that's all I totally forgot my second
question was because that answer
quarterback of the defense not only the
quarterback of the befit in high school
this has to be ready played you played
quarterback and linebacker led the team
in tackles hundred tackles you play
defense in high school - I play corner
running back corners one of the greatest
comedy that's a good company it's rare
that you see a linebacker hey I play
basketball - yeah I was a good athlete
back in back and long ago long long ago
but it's rare do you have a linebacker
and quarterback but that was out of
necessity and but I think that what
you're saying yes you communicate to
both sides it's really - doing the same
thing on both sides you communicate I'm
getting guys organized and ran the ball
a bunch you do it a little bit - I mean
it's it's a skill set but we talk about
leadership on around the league and
we're looking at some of these
quarterbacks young quarterbacks that are
struggling just a bit I think their
leadership is part of that - of course
in and that's why I also think that you
shouldn't write them off because that's
an easy thing to you can grow into it
you can with your I think it's hard to
get more accurate I think it's hard to
get a stronger arm I think you can
become a leader and I think you have to
have that gene yeah but I also think you
have to learn how to be a leader one
question before I get to the cup and
then your bag did you do the haka before
games ever no I never did the hot guy so
I okay go ahead I'm asking you during
questions and I'm happy so have you done
in your life or is that not part of your
culture I did it at the Polynesian a
Football Hall of Fame I was on stage and
I did you know didn't do it that we all
watched several people do it crew I just
followed along because they out of
respect it's I am up Samoan heritage but
I grew up in Boston a lot of them don't
know and so that's where the edge and
that's my question for the haka was
always I think it's one of the most
intriguing things I've ever seen it's
fascinating to watch the unison and the
energy but I've always wondered to be
yelling and expelling that much energy
right before a game and I think about
how you guys are always talking about
bottling it up and then letting it out
I've always wondered how do you let it
out like that
and then let it out again for the digit
counterproductive again it means so much
left look at the correlation of
performance then and in that case I got
to a quick story about this so I'm in
San Fran Mike Singletary is a coach and
you know big Isaac right yeah so he's
Samoan guy big me biggest man I've seen
before just huge and so now at practice
he wants to do that before we go play
Seattle
it makes like no we're not doing it that
was like one Thursday on Saturday Mike's
like let's practice it and so I'm like
man I can't believe we're doing this it
just wasn't my thing so then right
before the game literally in the locker
what to walk out singletery says listen
we're not doing the dance I don't care
what you do we practice it I didn't like
it we're not doing it
everyone just disregarded the coach we
come out and do the dance we get smashed
by 42 zip literally smash we're but
we're all doing the dance we're all
happy and we go out there first series
everybody's tired - you're my every
body's exhausted
we've been dance and we've been and I
don't know the dance but it was it was
involved you got to get you saw how
you're focused all the time and your
energy you know exhausted exhausted
reach into the cup what is this it's
random topics we have no idea producer
ever put it in it but don't read it yet
what voice should he have let's go back
to a traditional unless you Alan I was
gonna say gameshow voice gang show
voices argued unless you what about like
a cartoon voice like in the movie of
Moana duh duh father don't do I'm trying
to tell you that's a that's it that's a
Polynesian voice right
it is a Polynesian I'm gonna give you
just you have to read this in a game
show announcer all right it's time for
and now yes what's one concrete thing we
can do to fix the NFL refereeing
situation mm with a hard-hitting one I
think it's pretty easy to fix
okay let's hear it you got to get
full-time referees first of all okay
they have to be full-time so they have
to be doing their job getting better
just imagine if I'm working on Sunday
running up and down the field and then I
got to go to a real job my accounting
job on Monday so I looked into this Walt
Anderson's been an official in his life
for 44 years up until 2003 he was a ref
and a dentist okay hmm he's no longer a
debt that's a real job but my thing is
is so he's been a referee for 44 years
how I would make it better as two ways
one he said I found an interview with
him in 2003 where he said the game is
moving so fast and
we're trying to figure it out on the fly
and people at home have replay that's
right it's 2003 think about the
televisions that we had in 2003 think
about what the games look like in 2003
the replay the slow-mo about how much
older he is now exactly so one I believe
what the a AFL what the Alliance
whatever they had to this thing called
the eye in the sky where there would be
a referee that was up in a booth that
was watching the game and replay like
everybody else and could call down and
be like hey that was not an illegal
hands to the face on the dual alliance
so that's interesting you said something
on Monday Tuesday that what I say you
thought you you saw the referee like
this so they're talking to them yeah but
it's [ __ ] no the second thing to do
is the second thing I would do is I
would make the salary for a referee very
high in this country when we have jobs
that people don't like to do we pay them
more if you work in a coal mine we pay
you a large amount of money right who
wants to be a referee right everybody
[ __ ] you're crazy
who wants to go on TV ridiculed yeah
referees in college and in the in high
school that will love in a field job in
a referee are you because I love the
game but what are the qualifications is
it just experience no you got to be a
dentist you got to be orthodontic it'd
be I don't know but I mean it's a spirit
of this experience you start at college
you work your way and so that's how it
goes that's the official criteria for
getting in thinking yeah you know
because there's I think many people more
qualified that know about rules just I'm
talking former players and if they're at
all you know in love with the game then
they would be open to maybe a school for
officials right now like that and that
because they were used to making splits
decisions you know quick time real time
and not you know and then going in the
next play here's the concern with that
what's low 52 poo head referee for the
Super Bowl
it's the Seahawks versus the Steelers
Wow nobody knows I was gonna get to my
next point we needed to stop crying
about officiating people they're human
but if you want that game
had a huge referee thing with Ben
Roethlisberger go into it I'm gonna shut
up I mean D of course you have to bring
up that painful experience but um you
know which this I'll segue this into our
next speaking of trauma it's uh you know
that is and that's that's where I you
know I see these games and people
complaining about one call man we had
ten the least penalized team in the NFL
that year we had ten calls on us upon
return for 50 yards with Peter Warrick
that came back the the push off by DJ
ACK allegedly in the end zone when they
were both hustling the offsides by you
know the D end and they called us for
holding when the guy just slipped um
follow that madhouse whack throws a pick
and on his interest on the interception
return he you know went through is one
of the best plays I've seen he went
through the thigh boards of a lead
blocker and got to the carrier Wow and
stopped the touchdown and they threw a
flag on a block below the waist long no
yeah you go it was it was you know
called a block below the waist he wasn't
blocking for the guy he was tackling and
it's just so you know I've got fine for
just that 15,000 bucks one time just for
that yeah yeah I want an interception
well saw the thing is Wow I mean I
literally just typed in Seahawks
Steelers referee Super Bowl just to see
you it was and the first article that
pops up is referee bill Levy admits that
he screwed up and didn't understand the
rules of the game in the Super Bowl at
so it's funny because this is a thing
that happens every year what do you mean
doesn't understand the route they're
supposed to be the best rep that's why
you get the job I think at the time it
was irrefutable or indisputable yes
video evidence so I called it a real
time that way I have to you know which
is what they're doing now they are but
it was such a new rule then that kind of
like look at this pass interference rule
we don't know which way it's going now
they don't know when to call it and you
know it could cost you a challenge flag
and ultimately a timeout in the end or a
chance to review a bigger play that will
be you know more pivotal to the success
of the game so it's it's what I say is a
suck it up if you're good enough you'll
beat them we were not good enough that
day hats off to the Steelers they are
the Super Bowl champs because of your
humility we're gonna get back to the car
let's get to the bag what did you bring
us I know this is something you're
working on post-career and it's
something that I'm already in supportive
there it is
so this is a brand new CVD line Zone in
the products called balanced
there's several athletes with me backing
this invested in even and you know the
just if I could talk in little depth
about what it's done for me I could
explain and go to ours I would love to
know if you could do it in this vein NFL
players is the one player right now that
I think the public when we see someone
get hit or we hear the stories our heart
goes out to you guys because we know
that what you guys gave up for our
entertainment and the thing that's I
think the most frustrating is our nation
is going through an opioid epidemic and
we're seeing how much something like CBD
can alleviate those problems and I find
no group to need it more than probably
former football players and and the fact
that you have so many with you how is it
helping your post career oh I found it
three years ago and three years ago I
was 280 pounds I had ballooned up when I
was coaching in 15 and 16 late nights
late oh man you did they feed you good -
yeah thank you in awesome right so I got
up to 280 which is a hard look to pull
off at 511 and so with everything it
wasn't just the body that was shaking it
was the the mental toll that the game
took on me and you know and so with that
I had heard about CB for you know a
couple years before that but still
hadn't tried after career I got into the
industry and I gave it you know I gave
multiple multiple formulations to try
eventually stumbled across one that you
know I love and then when the farm bill
passed last December I you know went
about vetting out a lab to partner with
and you know making sure the
highest-quality full-spectrum even
commented CBDs disservice to the whole
plan right it's a full spectrum of you
know phyto cannabinoids and I can I
could geek out honest I can tell our
because we were talking before the show
a lot of people are throwing in CBD on
stuff and you don't know if it's real or
not wait and you it sounds like you
extensively went through and said I'm
gonna look at I had to know what was
impacting my life so much to move me
- you know hand it out buy it with my
own dime give it to friends that were
going through the same things I was
going through because of the FDA I can't
tell I can't share the whole experience
but in time testimonials and other
stories will you know can confirm what
I'm saying in the experience I've had
that's yeah you know you find people who
in us we have everybody how mammals
there's an endocannabinoid system and
what it is is receptors that this plant
and all of its phyto cannabinoids that
just means plant-based cannabinoids yep
it acts on those receptors cd1 and cb2
it puts you back in sync and I'm telling
you like I've never felt better and I've
never been better mentally physically
emotionally spiritually so how do you
how do you take it is it a morning thing
is it a night thing is it when you need
it that it's a what and when you need a
thing and your body will tell you cuz
you guys I'm and I need it all the time
so I know it like I look you wake up and
eat it
look I'm gonna explain something both of
you taken out as professional athletes I
hear you guys say this all the time you
know when your body doesn't feel right
I'm just letting you know I have never
been a to of my body like that like I've
just it's been a - you haven't had so
that's why well yet maybe so my thing is
is like the mental acuity part is what
I'm very interested but well cognitively
because everybody I'm sweating cause I'm
a big everybody sees everybody sees the
body transformation right and they're
just like wow what is it right but it's
nothing compared to how I feel and when
I talk about the cognitive you know in
terms of attention doing this segment
memory you know I was suffering through
short-term memory loss that's all coming
back and just you know being my best
self I feel it and I live it you know
daily the question I mean because you
talk about memory loss and obviously
I've dealt with to some concussions in
this by the way this is not gonna be
football player Brian Westbrook this is
venture capitalist price Rob we're at
here just in case you know I like to
invest and I I heard him going through
his thing and you were like oh my god
what kind of connectors is these you
know these words but you have to think
about how it affects can this help a
player a current player meaning a guy
that's going through it right now
because we're talking about things after
our career and infirm for me for you for
all X players the mints
aspect and then you look at all the
injuries hopefully I think this can
affect it but now as a current player
can this help me get over those things
quicker can it help me heal in the
meantime this is something that the NFL
for short obviously I think there in the
next CBA they're gonna allow cannabis to
you so they're gonna allow marijuana
there's no doubt about that but the CBD
in particular can this help guys to get
rid of the pain pill because I remember
they were handing out pain pills like
they were candy oh you're hurting taking
pain pills so let me give you a
prescription and then you see but you
own those commercials at nighttime hey
if you took this has you know you know
they're still considered a byproduct you
Animus you know attempter going to use
it you know the difference between the
two plants CBD from hemp and CBD from
canvas is still the same compound
molecularly structurally privatized so
you know it's I don't understand what
the you know the big fuss is about ya
know because you know so but in the
isolated form like I'm talking you know
when they it did pales in comparison to
a full spectrum or a full plant extract
I can't help players though I mean
absolutely can without a doubt I'm not
even gonna lie I would be wrapping up my
career right now rather than my career
started off great right as I wanted it
to three years three Pro Bowls and then
injury after injury whether it was
mental with concussions or it was
physical a knee surgery at about ten
surgeries eight from football yeah and
you're you're always on the mend you're
always you know and I've never had this
level of connectivity from my mind and
body that's dope dumb question it's not
oh it's nice that was actually my
question when I do my THC am I also
getting my CBD yeah what do you do for
in small small amounts at and depending
on how you're ingesting a frequency
about this so you can grow so different
strings of marijuana you're gonna be be
high in THC others can be high in CBD so
obviously if you're growing hemp a
little bit different but you want the
stuff that's high in CBD alright get in
there you have to do this it's my
favorite segment you have to do this in
the voice of Cheech and Chong
what voice is that
hey man yeah thank you
Holmes what's up bro
not a loud sleeper house for a whole
week man so there's no internet or TV
how do you pass your time and you're not
gonna be first this is an amazing
question forever you see you're stuck in
your home what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do to pass the time if you had
no form of distractions or media what
would you do what to do let me see that
question yeah I like you're stuck in
your house no TV no it's your knee
yeah what are you gonna do to pass your
time do I have movies no that's unlike
media is it with or without the kids
without the kids you are by yourself
just me with no nothing to distract you
how would you pass the time and you're
stuck there yeah that's a that's a
really complicated questions Adam Adam
does wait do I have books I well yeah I
think yeah you could read cell yeah
we're just taking away media like
television and movies and stuff and
social media yeah I would read I would
read would you I would try and meditate
really I would write no way I do in my
real time is that what you doing you're
yes I'll tell you this I like reading
reading I I enjoy reading but if I was
just frames like you know what I have
nothing to do like I have without the
kids it's a nervous I'm like now I'm not
gonna read I'm just gonna hang out I'm
just gonna do stuff around a house
probably clean up and vacuum vacuum the
house clean up I'm not reading no I'd
like to read but it's like I got you I
don't want to work today
all right Lofa what's your answer I said
yeah if it's not playing with the kids
and being active and getting outside you
know you're getting some fresh air then
yeah clean the house a read okay to
Ostra CBD and sown in balance it's the
only pill that gives you a thrill is it
a pill it's two different forms it's
actually it's so here's the dropper the
oil dropper with go that's good golf
course now it goes it is so there yeah
there's the PGA and there's
you know Bubba Watson he's been an
advocate for it I know and like there's
other sports that are you know either
not screening for it or not you know
penalizing person imagine common sense
Golf is such a mental game just imagine
your ability to get over the pain of my
knee and mentally focus in and if a my
back on my back and my ankle every
golfer is always like I don't know why
my backs hurt I'm like maybe because
you're repetitively swinging you're
about 80 times they got to do that for
four days
yes and then every day that leaderboards
changing they really I guess five right
go through 11 holes and I'm like I've
had enough and they're playing what is
it 72 moments I want the the cart person
you be with me on a golfer okay so what
voice am i doing this in Lofa I have no
idea this slope is your Pete Carroll's
voice I don't even know I kind of do
like Mike Singletary yes you got that
one down well I just what is what's the
dumbest thing you thought was true as a
child
what's the dumbest thing that you
thought was true as a child every every
kid has things that they thought were
true that were not true the dumbest or
what is one that comes to your mind that
you thought was real and wasn't my I
just thought of one it's a little
embarrassing or you get okay we're gonna
let it know yeah I got one two go ahead
all right mine's really gross I thought
that a man's testicles were grapes that
were not swallowed correctly and did
your parents tell you this worth how did
you how did you come to this
so I one day I was like I was like that
was like mom like I need to chew these
yeah she was like stop [ __ ] touching
them yeah that's not what they are you
need to those - I need more mental
acuity Telma - what what are you talking
I thought that like I had accidentally
swallowed grapes
and that that was my balls now yeah yeah
and your mom was the dumbest that I am
sweating so much right now
I gave it just a little more yeah yeah
all right well your parents that I have
two of them so your parents always tell
you you keep making that face you're
gonna be stuck with that oh good one
that happens all the time the other ones
so that that happens that I think you'd
get over I was so afraid to do
cross-eyed so I was gonna smack yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the other one as a
parent I I hear it and I actually start
thinking it so back in the day when you
were allowed to discipline your kids
my mother would already tell me that I'm
doing this because I love you as an
adult I'm like maybe maybe that's not
why you I understand what you're saying
but maybe that's not well so there is a
stage here life or shake it's all love
I'm doing I'm not disciplining because I
don't love you I'm doing it cuz I love
you I want you to do something more like
you know nicer you know the Easter Bunny
or you know you know that's how how old
were you when you learned about Santa in
the Easter but I mean it might have been
like second or third grade Wow it was
like kids on the bus I want my job and
so I was like nah you know that ain't
true
little Tommy Dreamer was like listen you
know Sam is a fraud
Brian and I went back to my mom and dad
as a yo does Kevin the bus said this
isn't real right what are you lying
somebody and Tommy has never lied he
knows everything
but yeah but that's just it's just about
the spirit right and just you know being
with around family and you know being
connected so I got over it relatively
quickly did you
with your kids did you let them believe
in Santa or I hope then I watched in
Santa still real yes it's real
Wow don't release this did I tell you
the two lemurs of Santa Ana who are
parent bribery and fear you have to use
bribery this Santa Claus thing is
straight so you can get your kids act
good from Halloween to Christmas Santa
is watching yeah I use this elf thing
you know oh my goodness
my daughter loves this thing I took her
every day if you were bad yesterday L
finish up went home I'm gonna be using
it for the Shelf year round yes he's not
coming I was above the first grader yep
the best part is actually hiding there
and seeing that I signed it and I
actually get a little R because I it's
kind of like out in plain sight so when
my oldest you know he's you know not in
the moment all the times you have a
great imagination sometimes he doesn't
find it when it's like on the kitchen
table right oh it's right there hot hot
hot lava thank you for coming in where
can people find zone and balance what
website what with social media all that
zone and CBD calm give us a following
insta Facebook and is that also at zone
and CBD yes and zone and CBD an
e-commerce site and so yeah we're
excited about it and the zone and
wellness is you know a Facebook page
calm that you can go and check out more
we're gonna be the storytelling you know
we're all athletes nice everybody's
athlete so we're just going to go around
correcting you know collecting all these
stories and you know you know putting it
out there and giving people you know
positivity energy and you know it's a
brand that aspires to inspire and so
that's what it's good to see athletes
not only giving it back to the immediate
athletes guys that are playing down but
also giving back there to the community
it's a much bigger community outside of
the guys are playing alumni of the town
that need this I don't need this I just
got hit up by a couple of Hall of Famers
so yeah if they you know let me release
their names down the road I will and but
they they love the product grain they
love what it's done for me so I'm
excited to use it to Lofa thank you or
key right back and we're gonna break
down the crazy trades of Jalen Ramsey
and Marcus Peters stay with us
fluff was the man Lofa is the man just a
great dude solid too
polynesian background obviously but
there are so many guys that I played
with with Polynesian back background
Reno ma hey by second Hema I didn't play
with them but I know library well Isaac
that we talked about in San Francisco
just great dudes there's such good
people that I go man I wish my people
were like that you know what I wish I
wish more people just I wish our people
we're like they're more be more giving
more into like I just want to help
others oh I wish all of our people will
take his cup though yeah get that out of
here get that take his D and then let's
check it out but we're gonna we're gonna
use some CBD later so the two big moves
yesterday I was on Mina Kimes this
podcast when the Peters thing came out
huh and I I was very confused I went
this is a Rams team that just put a keep
to Levon IRA that there are starting
safety john johnson has a shoulder
injury that they're saying could last
for weeks and then you're gonna trade
Marcus Peters and we were sitting there
looking at the depth chart going who do
they even have left no clue and then
they make this move for Jalen Ramsey I
think that is the bigger move so let's
talk about that one first and then we'll
get back to Marcus Peters but Jalen
Ramsey for two first-round picks and a
fourth round pick yeah teams across the
NFL are upset
Eagles fans are freaking out Chiefs fans
are freaking out Titans fans are
freaking out I am upset because now I
owe you a money yes you do owe me well
now we're even
what are we I won the Chiefs line yes
you did then you won this or even right
now but I feel I kind of feel like since
you owe me the money
more recently then I should get two
money's because you were so wrong the
Detroit Lions weren't even in the
conversation we don't know who is and
they haven't they have a good secondary
already - yeah well you're not getting -
are you owe me - money no I jumbled the
money this works but Jalen Ramsey on the
Rams you know I have so many questions
do you believe first that two
first-round picks in the fourth round
pick for Jalen is a good return for the
Jags for the best for the best
cornerback in the league for the last
few years
he can play man-to-man he can play zone
he can take the ball away from the other
team so he changes the
possessions obviously give you an extra
possession he's like 24 years 24-year
old long arms athletic physical I I
don't have a problem with the
compensation I think that I don't know
was gonna cluster going break right so
you get a guy that can shut down if you
believe one pretty sign long term well
that's the thing yeah if you can and I
have to believe that he wants to resign
there he wants to go there in in 40 min
really he's the team the Rams have lost
all of their leverage so they're gonna
have to pay him which you should expect
to pay pay him the highest paid
defensive contract in the league that's
just simple so I don't have a problem
with the compensation you're gonna have
to pay him I think this team as a whole
they're going in the wrong direction
Tom Coughlin came out and said the goal
is still to in the division I think it's
interesting because I look at their
division and I look at the Texans
you and I go that's a team that you
would probably need Jalen Ramsey against
I look at the Colts and I go with T wise
healthy you need a minute but you know I
think I wonder if Jacksonville held the
Saints to 13 points and said you know
what without Jalen Ramsey were still
able to do this and we'll figure this
out it's addition by subtraction and I
think they also realized that Jalen was
never coming back he didn't want to come
back I mean he made up every excuse to
baby in the back and he he didn't want
to be there anymore it was in his mind
ik so it this way I thought I thought
garden men she was playing well and
maybe you could convince him to come
back because the team had a chance now
they're two and four and you have no
reason to come back if you're Jalen
Ramsey I want to be out of here I hate I
hate the Jackson field I want to be
somewhere else and if I got a chance to
go to the Rams in LA that's the place I
want to be and so of course you're not
gonna talk him back to coming back into
a team that's two and four he's used
every excuse in the book not to be there
and so I with that though man
the Rams are the most top-heavy team in
terms of salaries in the NFL absolutely
you do not trade two first-round picks
in a fourth round pick for Jalen Ramsay
and do not sign him to course again and
we know that Jalen Ramsay is expecting
to be pay as the highest cornerback in
the NFL right now they're paying Donald
17 a year
Whitworth just under 17 a year cooks
over 15 a year Dante Fowler 12 million
dollars a year
Michael brokers just under 11 million
dollars a year and the Jared Goff
contract
the todd gurley contract well i mean you
had to imagine he's gonna be the
highest-paid cornerback I'm thinking he
probably won't get seventeen so you're
not gonna be hired in town I'm thinking
fifteen sixteen you know fifteen and a
half sixty me actually go back and see
who the highest-paid is by position
because I think that's what it usually
comes down to is who what is he he wants
to be the highest-paid there's one about
in the NFL yeah I mean I think he gets
15 between 15 and 6 is probably I think
the highest-paid is by 15.3 at this
point but you know there's a lot of
teams that were saying you know what the
asking price is too high
our Philadelphia Eagles the asking price
is too high I would never give that up
what do you mean what have you done with
your last two number one pigs what have
you put in a position for success with
those last two opportunities you picked
in there so the sabian Howard is a
little bit over 15 Norman's at fifteen
Tremaine Johnson's at 14.5 Xavier Rhodes
is 14 Patrick Peterson is 14 I'm gonna
tell you what he's much better than all
those guys means Peterson like his
deception all of those guys were paid
and then didn't produce upon payment and
Jalen is going hey by the way Norman's
31 Tremaine John's 29 all that stuff and
then you look down and this guy is like
under 20 he's 24 years old well just
think of Josh Norman I'll just use him
as an example he wasn't a shutdown
cornerback he was a he was a he was a
nominal zone call zone guy yeah just
scheme type of thing you put Jalen
Ramsey against your best player just go
listen go lock similar to Dion go lock
him down and now it listen every corner
back gets balls caught on them but he's
one of those guys that he'll compete to
the end he's a football player I don't
know that he had problems in the locker
room no teammates no he had a
disagreement with the coach none but it
was funny because when he had a
disagreement with the coach when he was
playing all of his team is same except
in you have nothing to worry about Jalen
Ramsey from a personnel purse
personality perspective here's my thing
though one gonna do a positive for the
Rams
Aqib Talib one on IR yep but he couldn't
return in week 15 so in week 15 and if
this team can make her on the play it
matters you have a keep Talib in jail
and Ramsey
you can cover any team in the NFL any
team you're shutting it like those two
quarterbacks is the best corner duo in
the league I felt the same way about
Marcus Peters but go ahead I'm right but
Jalen Ramsey is a lot better than
marketers because Marcus teeters Peters
will take risk and apparently the locker
room did like Marcus Peters but he
doesn't fit that system all the time I
don't know that he knew would d think
they were playing there's a lot of stuff
he would freelance a little bit on that
but my concern with the Rams is part of
the reason I was worried is when I went
and broke down their roster before the
year I went this team is so top-heavy
that that if any of these guys get hurt
then the blow is crippling also my other
issue was this wasn't even the biggest
issue for the team that's the biggest
issue that I see huge issues on the
offensive line
I don't trust Jared Goff at the same
time if Wade Phillips believes that what
what he did in Denver where he had Chris
Harris jr. and Aqib Talib if he believes
he gets those two corners that this
defense with Donald can step up to a
level then it takes some pressure off
the offense interesting my other thought
is the CBA is coming in 2021 okay I
don't think it's gonna go well I still
believe that the Rams really look like
they're going look we're gonna spend all
of our monies yeah before 2021 trying to
and we'll see what happens with the NFL
at that point Jared Goff is an issue
Todd Gurley you didn't mention him of
course that's a big issue kid that's
often score and I'm not worried because
I still think Doug early Malka Brown and
Daryl Henderson is a really good trio
really I think so we haven't what I've
seen out of Henderson last week against
the Niners the few of the ways he hit
the edge I went oh that kid can move we
haven't we haven't seen that consistent
we haven't seen his offers do very much
consistently the the biggest thing and
it was a question let's say that you had
a feeling you were gonna get Ramsey you
know you put to leave on injured reserve
why did you get rid of Peters again
because I mean again you're trying to
win games you're trying to your salary
related maybe maybe it is maybe and
maybe he signed you signed a contract
Ramsey at this point but don't you have
to play some games before you get to
leave back you still gotta win some
games I mean just imagine putting it all
on Jalen right now yeah but just imagine
this though I don't know who's the other
cornerback nobody knows what happens if
you put my I put the receiver in motion
put money other side
Troy Hill yeah exactly I'm Nicole Roby
Coleman who's a very good slam throwing
at those guys it mean that's that's what
you're gonna do and now the defense team
shaven long in the other ground I'm just
giving information I keep up giving up
big plays to me I would have especially
with Talib on injured reserve I would
have kept Peters and still try to get
Ramsey now I don't know how to salary
cap I don't know any of those things but
that's what I would have tried it
heaters was in a contract year yeah and
so that's part of the reason they
weren't gonna pay I would've cut them I
mean I got the entity you got to get rid
of and so you're not gonna pay him again
you get you get a linebacker for EM
return from Baltimore which is cool but
you got to win games this team has to
win game if this team doesn't make the
playoffs this year which is this is a
reasonable assessment that you couldn't
make the playoffs dude listen the 49ers
are winning the bunch of games the
Seattle Seahawks are winning but one of
those two teams are gonna win a division
and that's what's so interesting to me
is you look at the two biggest
competitions for them in the West the
Niners do not have a number one wide
receiver no they are based on running
running just whip tight ends and
underneath route that's right the
Seahawks they have Tyler Lockett but
they're not a team based on wide
receiver play no so in your own division
you have two teams that are focused on
running the football and you strengthen
the part of your football team that
maybe wasn't the biggest issue I'm just
saying this now it's going to look
really good because the Rams are playing
the Falcons this weekend but we could
see Jalen Ramsey kind of get tore up a
little bit but the Rams offense the next
two weekends the Falcons and the Bengals
all signs are pointing the bay the rams
going from three and three to five and
three into a bi okay and it's gonna look
a little bit better but I don't know how
I feel about the Rams overall the one
that I think might have more
implications for the playoffs because I
have more confidence in this team being
a playoff team because of their their
current record at four
- and their standings in their division
is the Ravens the Marcus Peters trade to
me is very interesting
the Ravens secondary has been abysmal
yeah they just lost Tony Jefferson yeah
they've had Jimmy Smith injured all year
all year but if Jimmy Smith comes back
and they have Marcus Peters and they
have not Lattimore Roe Thomas is back
there to write the [ __ ] from
Alabama who I always forget Oh Marlon
Humphries thank you
Marlon Humphries Marcus Peters Jimmy
Smith is a hell of a dream really good
trio and that's the kind of trio you
need to play man-to-man against the
Kansas City Chiefs if you get if you get
the good Marcus Peters right because
we've seen an undisciplined unfocused
kid that has so much touted this is this
is a scary part but I saw him coming
over from Kansas City I know I'm seeing
a player that no one can run around
against he could run with as fast as
anybody in the league when he breaks on
the ball he's taken it he's shaken and
he catches the interceptions all the
times great hands but I kind of feel as
though he was unfocused he wasn't
focused on playing the game he was more
about doing other things and we know the
talent that that's the hard part when
you see young guys you like man listen
you're so talented you're much more
talented than anybody else out there
you're not fulfilling that potential I
hope that he goes to Baltimore and John
Harbaugh is able to refocus him that
those guys around them Jimmy Smith Earl
Thomas Martindale all those guys can
refocus them and say listen this is all
I need you to do they don't think about
this don't think about that you're not
on the West Coast anymore where you're
from now you're in the East Coast let's
think about hard-nosed football and
playing that if you could refocus this
kid it's gonna be tough to throw against
that Ravens secondary it's very
interesting because the Ravens this week
play the Seahawks mm-hm and it's in
Seattle that's right and so you look at
this Seattle team that - two Thursday's
ago played Marcus Peters yeah and took
advantage of him on a number of plays
and now he has to go back there again so
he does know this team well which is
interesting I do think it's good for the
Ravens that they have a bye week after
this game yeah to really get him up to
speed but the thing that I am excited
about is if that ball goes up and Peters
gets his hand on him and he's wearing a
Ravens uniform and he starts streaking
across the field it's gonna look
beautiful yeah there are certain teams
that I like when certain types of
players are on them a shit-talking pick
six thriving defensive back with a
motormouth and wheels is a raven well
that's how the road is built and let me
tell you that Marcus Peters there's
times where I think he's Marcus Peters
was born to be a Raider
and a raven and I think he's on one of
those teams right now
I like that we'll see you know like that
were you thinking you think you know
right you don't look beautiful what
they're gonna write where but I also
know that at the same point like I look
at the Ravens and it's like your defense
is already getting shredded so at least
you have a guy that if he guesses right
can really make a big play but we'll see
the problem with the Raver
the Ravens as I watched her defense the
but the talent all over the dog won't
feel a bunch of solid everywhere they
have so many mental errors though I mean
they're just messing up simple things
that every deficient knee every
difference a person knows they're just
messing it up and again you tell my
refocusing a player you need to refocus
that entire defense you're just too good
for these types of things that happen
another part is this you're one of the
best teams in the AFC period top three
teams in the AFC you have a chance of
maybe going up to New England and
playing them in the playoffs and trying
to get into the Super Bowl this is the
time now to fix all those small things
this is a time now that you say listen
if we could get these couple things
these mental errors fixed up we can roll
towards the playoffs that's the type of
defense that they can have with all the
players that they have on that defense I
think it could be really interesting I
just want to get a few injuries out
there for people as we start looking
ahead to this weekend's game the Bears
putting Hakeem Hicks on injured reserve
is monumental yeah the big story that we
talked about with Warren the last two
weeks the Raiders game and the week
before were the Bears they were kind of
able to get running a little bit Akeem
Hicks was hurt so now he's on injured
reserve let's watch and see
what happens to this bears defense he's
the guide next to Khalil Magda you also
to be worried about Cowboys defensive
end Tyrone Crawford huge having hip
surgery another guy on a D line that's
been surprisingly underperforming they
were deep they're getting shallow watch
out for Dallas also this Amari Cooper
lingering hamstring issue I do not like
really good athletes with leg issues be
guys definitely so and I'm going wow and
you're taking on the Eagles and the heck
what did you think about Doug Peterson
saying we're gonna win on Sunday I don't
think that he said it exactly that he
didn't guarantee it I think he was just
like we're gonna go down there and win a
game so in my mind I think every head
coach who say that yeah but it's
Philadelphia they're crazy and they read
it as a guarantee and that's good so
what so what so what if you guarantee
you win what else am I supposed to say
because when I talk to my team and I
expect every other coach to say the same
thing listen we need to go down
everywhere I guarantee a win inside of
this locker room I don't think his
statement was taken the right way but I
wouldn't I wouldn't even mind a lot of
problems a thing a wink of sleep over it
I would say yeah I said that yeah you
take it however you want to I read into
this and it scared me a lot Alvin Kamara
has a quote high ankle type issue that's
a quote that's a problem why is it that
when I hear high ankle sprain yeah I get
shivers down my spine
you should why well because first Laura
had one pieces I don't even know if I
have a low ankle yeah you don't want to
have a cankle kinkle listen oh you're
gonna die I can see you're getting
slimmer I've eaten really well the last
three I could tell I'm looking at you if
you look you look slim do like do
something you gotta suck it in in the
cheeks a little bit yeah there you go
there you know that here's a problem
with athletes athletic guys like Camaro
with with these types of injury high
ankle well you have to eat he cuts a lot
he makes people's miss he make people
miss he is an explosive guy it's about
lateral quickness we have an out right
we're on your leg is the high ankle so
the low ankle is kind of like underneath
the little knot on your ankle underneath
that yeah I think it was a little bit
higher so you get a little separation
right between that little my ankle and
my calf yeah and so that's a high okay
and when you get that little separation
your stability so you're stretching out
the ligaments a lot so it really is
yellow when you cut you feel you feel it
all the time
damn when you're cut and here's the
thing you want to put the ankle wrap on
there tighter and so now your foot is
throbbing because you got a doggone
ankle wrap trying to support your ankle
because your ligament has drugs going to
your face so it's all bad and so the
ligaments are the things that keep you
being able to make those move it's
almost better to break your ankle it
everybody it sounds crazy but if you
just broke your ankle bones can heal
very very quickly as long as you don't
do any damage these ligaments and
tendons they don't heal very fast I had
a high ankle sprain and I came back wait
I played the next week which was a
mistake
I wasn't very healthy I was I didn't
help my team and now I have bone spurs
because of that and it's totally bad so
a new your high ankle sprain you look at
a guy and go he's not gonna be right for
four to six weeks
well I'll tell you this when I hear high
up the spring I heard it was say Quan I
said I hope they don't let this kid play
for six weeks and they're doing the
absolute right thing yeah and come back
by saying nope nope nope because listen
this is a long-term thing for six take
one you want to Kim healthy play nothing
for camara same exact thing I wouldn't
let him play but at the same time you're
riding the win streak your team's
playing well try to aesthetic rules
heady needs to help because I'm just
saying that this is an interesting game
where the Bears it's bear Saints in
Chicago and it's gonna be nasty the
visitors the Bears just lost Hakeem
Hicks so you go okay well they may be
the Saints with that great offensive
line might actually have an advantage
yeah and then I look at the Saints and I
go this team has been based on Alvin
Kamara and Michael Thomas it and now
they're not gonna have that so but yeah
latavius marries a fabulous Marie and
then I guess your third string
quarterback mmm Taysom Hill and they
also have that speedster that every time
he's on national TV they talk about he
returns punts and kicks I don't know if
he'd go back there but there was another
injury in this game that I just
remembered that I think is interesting
that no one talked about which one's the
long brother on how long I think he's on
IR two so the Bears quietly in the spy
week maybe put their best o-line and
their one of their best D lineman on IR
it's still chase Daniel time that's a
weird game I've been wrong on every
Saints game this year I'm not betting
that game well the Bears played great at
home defensively yes they did they get
out there the quarterback so Teddy has
to make sure that he's pinpoint accurate
gets the ball out quickly which he's
been doing to be honest with you how are
they gonna handle Michael Thomas but not
having that one weapon in the backfield
healthy III hope that they don't play
chimera but and they may all I know is
that game I'm looking let's see what the
under is I just want him to be healthy
and listen I've dealt with this injury
for a long time and I still deal with
the every single day that ankle is
something serious especially for a
shifty type of running back like c'mere
because when he's out in space Oh Mike
there's nobody in league that can deal
with them with the healthy Hank the
over-under in that game is 38 right now
and I would still bet the under I would
bet they're under two I just think with
that good same events and that Bears
offense no chase Daniel I would duck
humming often will buy at home and we
know the splits on that the only other
question I ask you is a question that
Mina Kimes asked me we're doing this
before Thursday Night Football
it is Kansas City at Denver if my home's
his ankle is at all messed up would you
sit him for this game and give him the
extra 10 days of rest or would you play
in I said absolutely not I'm playing
this guy this was a very similar
situation to when he solidified himself
to all the haters last year when he beat
Denver and he threw a pass with his left
hand at the same time his Denver defense
has come alive yeah they have now
granted they've shut down Tennessee and
Jacksonville the last two weeks and this
is a different animal
but Denver always play as Kansas City
well I would play him and they play
there's no doubt about I would play him
but this is the beauty of my homes he
could play the position from the pocket
he couldn't he could go three steps and
let the ball out he could do five steps
and let the ball out
he says his athletic ability allows him
to do all that crazy stuff and all the
things that we love about him makes him
an MVP choice last year but he could
play the game from the pocket puncher
and so I think also I think Andy Reid
tries to run the football this game this
is his
is mo one game he doesn't run it the
next game he pours it on so I think they
run the ball an awful lot but I think my
Holmes is skilled enough to play from
the pocket and I also think that he's
just a gamer and Hilke he'll he's one of
these kids that if you don't play him
he'll just bug the hell out of you until
you see some colleges play you so that's
the type of kid he is Denver right now
fourth best defense in the NFL
allowing under 18 points a game 17.7
number four against the pass and in
terms of against the run scrolling
scrolling 18th yeah so this is a team
run a football that Vic Fangio he's able
look we talked about earlier in this why
it's a good place to wrap up
if Andy is going to get a little bit
repetitive Vic Fangio is gonna find all
of your attendance he goes out about and
he's gonna find a way to take all of
them away this is a defensive line that
especially in Denver can get after a
quarterback this is a game that when I
saw I went people are gonna be a little
bit too high on Denver because they beat
Tennessee and like if he sucks they
stink so I'm like oh I can bet against
Denver and then I said I bet you people
are gonna start doubting Kansas City are
they gonna win are they gonna lose three
in a row
that's the question well and Erie City
Chiefs team lose three in a row two of
which were at home which is mind blowing
so the last two losses right now the
spread opened at Kansas City favored by
four and a half okay it is down to three
okay
City is favored by three on the road in
Denver Brian Westbrook we have not done
this yet this year what would you pick
this offense for Kansas City has just
looked average at best the last three
women they just looked okay 19 points
against Andy for 24 points against
Houston I believe that Andy Reid has had
to be in the lab trying to figure these
things out I think he runs the ball gets
LeSean McCoy in and out of the backfield
catching the football
I think pass him her homes refocuses
doesn't throw an interception like he
did last week I think that they go out
there and they win the game by more than
was it three three yeah I think they
went by more than three
Denver so last year in this same
situation it was a tight game the entire
time and Patrick mahomes came back so it
was 13 to 10 in the second quarter it
was the Denver Broncos last year in week
four right around the same time hosted
Kansas City and was up 23 to 13 in the
fourth quarter with seven minutes left
mahomes came back and led to touchdown
drives and they won 27 to 23 to win that
game and I do not think they covered no
but they won well but do you know what
happened in that game that they don't
have right now
Kareem hunt run game 19 carries a
hundred and twenty-one yards and that's
really my issue right now at this Kansas
City team is kind of like Deron Williams
we kind of like Darryl Williams yes we
kind of like Darwin Tom's yeah we kind
of like LeSean McCoy but you don't love
any of them they haven't found a guy and
I don't know the Andy loves any of them
just chummy he's not gonna give him a
koi 20 carries it's just not gonna
happen
the other thing that I like about this
Broncos teams I like the running back
group the idea - I like Freeman I like
Lindsey I like both of those guys
because you got that thunder and
lightning lightning type of deal Lindsey
and I watched them all last year very
very closely in the beginning this year
speed quickness can hurt you out of the
backfield and this this Chiefs team has
been susceptible to the run but however
an offense can beat you they've done
that against this Chiefs team and so
even though I don't believe in Joe
Flacco any longer I think that this
Denver Broncos team can run the football
down the throat and then they could play
action you just enough against a bad
secondary for for the Broncos to beat
you I mean the Chiefs to beat you and so
offensively the Chiefs had to be able to
put pressure on the Broncos to make them
depend on Joe Flacco because if they
start the run game going which I know
they're gonna try to do I think the
Chiefs have a very hard time stopping
the Broncos doing that I'm trying to see
we are recording this on Wednesday I'm
just trying to see if Chris Jones is
practicing right all right that's it now
now I'll tell you about Chris Jones
that's
that no one's talk grown man he's
amazing he's huge
he's physically dominant the one thing
that you went from an interior rusher is
a guy that can put his hands on you he
could move office Lyman left to right so
he could look to the left look to the
right and Chris Jones is one of the best
in the league when when healthy his
ability to do that well I'm sure he's
gonna push Jones did not practice on
Tuesday
it's a groin issue that hurts and
there's nothing I like less than a
defensive lineman with a groin issue
maybe he doesn't practice just so that
he's ready to play short week short week
Sammy Watkins limited saying with a
hamstring and Jamie's been hurt his
whole career and that's the tough thing
there is a chance Denver gets back to
Juan James there is a chance that Derek
Wolfe does play the Kansas City right
now
banged up I think if I had to bet I
would take the three points and Denver
at home and it's really weird it's but
it's it's a game that I think I if
Denver jumps atop early yes I know that
they could the cheese can come back but
Denver can really pound this rock at the
same point if Andy Reid dials up some
screens and jumps ahead to a 10 nothin
14-nothing lead guess what they might
win by 30 yeah
I'm just eating this for the record I
have not gotten a single Thursday night
game right this year I don't bet
Thursday Night Football it's the
weirdest so if I'm saying Denver ant I
got it bet the cheese there you go
that's why I trust you I don't trust
your good lawful was the man again his
product I'm gonna try that today man I
need a balance I'm gonna take it with
some water right now but a little
dropper on the Ton Ton yeah a little fun
[ __ ] calm down a little down down
I am the lef koe man the cup is always
fun for low 52 [ __ ] Brian Westbrook
the rocket man we never got his nickname
alright I think he skipped out he didn't
want to give him a nickname loaf of the
loofah loaf of not a probably what that
he's a physical nasty linebacker dude he
looks like he could play yeah he looks
Jack and I'm now and I telling you he
was nasty on the field he's a nice guy
but he was nasty on the field love that
you're the man you guys are the homies
33 percent appreciate y'all be back with
Warren coming up later this week peace
out love you peace out bye-bye
[Music]